um now I understand uh you know a lot of
people come out here they move to Los
Angeles they don't like the driving they
hate the driving you love driving don't
you I love driving yeah did you you you
drive yourself everywhere I drive
everywhere they were going to send a
town did you get a town car Marissa to
come over here yeah I did see I declined
well I liked I like to drive you never
know what you're gonna encounter it's
exciting I was driving over here I get
behind a minivan sweetest little bumper
sticker on the back of the minivan it
says honk if you love Jesus right yeah
so I pull up and I'm like
minivan does 12 flips into the ditch
blows up oh my God yeah now the bad news
is the people died the good news is now
they're with Jesus okay you
you're a bad guy
murderer I'm fed to the Bone George Thor
good hello
now
we're talking about your podcast on your
podcast recently you you talked about
baby pandas I didn't hear what you were
talking about what was what's your head
baby well every time a baby panda is
Born the whole world goes berserkoids
huh baby panda born who cares man nobody
nobody takes a fit when anything else is
born
have you ever been born
yes I was born once yeah you have kids
don't you yes I do and I got pretty
excited when they were born did you
watch them come out
yeah
yes I did well this is creepy well no
invasion of my this is crazy but yes I
did I watched my children being born see
I couldn't do that I would freak me out
as like a bunch of people standing
around waiting for something to come out
it's like Groundhog Day in there
I couldn't watch a little human come out
because when I was a kid I played a lot
of whack-a-mole
no you wouldn't no you wouldn't that's
crazy you know what sucks about being a
baby though when you're born as soon as
you come out the doctor smacks you right
to get your adrenaline going to pop you
into the world and uh here's what I say
they should do to get the baby's hearts
a race and Young fella
they should put the women up on the roof
of the hospital right put them right on
the edge of the roof baby pops out it's
standing there it's already got the
bungee cord
[Applause]
welcome to the world little fella
thank you
I don't want to ask this last thing it
says here on the card that you brought
something I don't even want to know what
you brought that's scary at this point
hold on Space Rider you're gonna like
this
who's space Rider I don't know I just
thought if you had a CB radio I could
give you a handle okay well what did you
bring there Chopper I made a toy do you
like toys you have kids yeah they like
them you're gonna love this I made this
myself this is an amazing toy for kids
it's called Timmy the magic onion bun
bun and what you do is you eat it in a
day and a half later it comes out a
different shape
[Applause]
[Laughter]
how many do you half of those things I
had a feeling you'd throw them into the
ocean
hahaha
something's really wrong with you well
this book is available on Amazon
.com
and the Harlan highway is available on
iTunes and at harlanwilliams.com you are
an original you were an original
waiting to be right back